[音楽]
皆さんこんにちはちょっと若い写真が写ってね
恥ずかしいんですけれども
8今日はですねあんまり楽しくない話をしなきゃいけないなぁと思ってきたんです
けれどもただ
未来につなげるためにとても大切な話をしようと思っています
私普段何やってるかというともともとはね建築が仕事なんですけれどもまぁそこにへ
スタートしてですね今はこの画面に映っている
南海トラフ巨大地震これと戦うファイターの一人だと戦うって言ってもねあれなんです
けども
今日はまあこの話と皆さんがこれから先100年後を考えたときにどんなことを考えて
おかなきゃいけないのかなということを考えてみたいというふうに思います
で
本題に入る前にですね今日は皆さんにクイズをしてみたいと思います
ねえ
第一問なんですけれども日本の面積はどれぐらいだったか知ってますか
なんの話だという話ですけどね
ねぇ
これね
あてませんのでどれぐらいの人があります
偉いですね今日は意識高い人が多いとはいうものの音後6人です手が挙がったのは
ね中学校でやるとこれね半分ぐらいてが上がりますよ
答えはですねおおよそ38万平方キロメートルなんですあたってましたかなんでこんな
話をするかというとですねあとねドイツの心理学者に
ヘルマイビハウスという人がいましてこの人はですね
何かというと人間は8あまり意味のないもの生い茂るを覚えようとしてもまあ覚えられ
へんよと合わせて言ってしまうと
で覚えていられるものっていうのはまあ繰り返し繰り返し思い出すことだ
でね
38万平方キロメートルって中学校で習ってから今日僕に聞かれるまで
役に立ったことありましたか
ねえあんまり役に立たないですよねってことはみんな今日の今日までそれを思い出す
ことなく彼の雪にはまって忘れてしまったということになるわけですねー
面白い話何の話かってだんだんわかってきますからねで次に何の指紋しようかと思っ
てるんですけども
勉強っていうのは38万平方キロメートルを
覚えると思うから面白くないんですよ先ほどね受験勉強の話ありましたけどね面白く
ない勉強を将来のためにする案ではその部ないんですけども
でも例えばこの問題だったらどうでしょう
世界の陸地のうちその日本の38万平方キロメートルでどれぐらい買って急に君がある
話になると思いませんか
ねぇこれはが
います
難しいですねさん宅にしましたので心の中でてあげてくださいね
一番25%
聞こえます皆さんの心の声世界中から黄ばみそんなアホなんですよね
2番2.5%3番0.25%道ですあげましたどっかにね
心の汚れた大人は多分3番にてあげましたよね
根市版はこんな内部そんなこのアホなんですよねでこれが2番が答えやとしたら
ちょっと家として弱いでしょ
だから多分3番やクイズに支払う
だから世界です
ねぇなんでそんなこと言うのかってこれ小学校通している時はねまあるいケーキ買って
きて家族4人で食べるときどうやって着ると教えるんですよねそうよちんできるじゃ
ないですか
その一つは一番ですよね3番手
その一つの1/4のケーキを100個に切ることをよって小学生に教えるんですちょ
小学生三茶管理します
そんなちーさんやこの国はあって
たぶんねその小学生おうちへ帰ってお母さんにこう言いますお母さん日本ではドルが
小さいか知ってるって
ケーキ4つに切ってそれ102くるは小さいねレイヤー
すばらしいですよねこれで何でこんな事言うかっていうとね翼羽根うちの大学は東京
ドーム15分とか言うじゃないですか
東京ドーム中國文て言ってるくせに東京ドームの面積知ってる人あんまりいないんです
よ
ん
勉強って側テープに立っているわけ何の話かってね
だんだん近づいてきますから我慢して聞いてくださいね
次の問題はじゃあそれ人口でやるとどうかってちょっと先を急ぎますのでことは言い
ますけれどもだいたい1パン1.8%安の日本の人口世界の多いと思いませんか
多いんですよ世界で10番目に多い国です
あちなみに面積はですね61番目です
ですか中学校の社会科ではこの国はすごく小さいくせにいっぱい人が住んでる国だって
こんな now んですよね
それで
さらにだんだんだんだん私の世界に連れて行きます
2004年から2013年のこの国で発生したマグニチュード6以上の地震て何回
ぐらいあったか知っています
心の中でね数値皆さん思い浮かべてくださいこの日本でマグニチュード6以上の地震が
この10年間で何回起こったか思い出してくださいに一生懸命
マグニチュード6って言うのはねえっとこの間大阪であった自身もそうなんですけども
あれぐらいです最低でね
なんか食らったでしょう
答えはなんと300回です
そうそうええでしょびっくりですよね
そんなにあるんですで次の問題は者世界中で起きるマグニチュード6のうちこの300
会が何パーセントかってね僕のだんだんはながわかってきましたよね
これはなんと
自由9%2割です復習しますよ
面積は0.25しかなくて人口にパーでそれで自信は20パーです割に合いませんで
この国に住むことは
そう思いませんか他にもね色んな数字あるんですよ
例えば111個ってなんだと思います世界の7%これは火山の数ですひどじゃないです
か
0.25%がしかないのに7%の火山がこの国にあるんですよ
他には
11.4545%これはねちょっと割り算する数字が違うんですけれどもこれはね
太平洋で発生する音熱帯性低気圧台風という奴が日本に代々1年間に発生した分の4割
がやってくるんですよ
わりにありません
で僕たちはどう考えているかそれでも世界的に見ますとねこれだけ自然災害を切る国に
1億人も住んでるなんてまあ言った悪いけどあの人たち顎やねえ
要はあなたが住んでるわけでも皆さんこの国に住む理由があるじゃないですかね
我々の国は縄文式土器作ってたような時代から今まで一度も滅びることなく反映を続け
て今でもみんな幸せに住んでるじゃないですかそれをねこれだけ自然災害が起こっ
たってその自然のことをよく理解して
で
その自然を起こすことに対してそれから身を守るための知恵や技術を培ってきたから
です
自信もってください日本の皆さん
この国は防災がとっても強い組です
でもね僕はこう思うんです
その知恵というのをこの100年間でだんだん失ってやしませんか
私の仕事はそれをもう一回リバイバルすることですねー弁当芸能のリバイバルですよ
リバー貼るなんて言うと怒られるかもしれませんけどねでも僕達持ってたんでそれを
だから今までこれたでもね今見ると例えば
ん
閉栓見てみると皮の中に住んでる人いますよね海抜僕の家アニメーターだといやいや
それ川の底やねんって
でもねテープを作って水を書き出すと住めるような感じになるんですよ
いやたに埋めてね谷の上に団地作って僕の家はネタ課題でいいとこできやそれもとは誰
に屋根それ雨2崩れるでって
そんな感じしませんか昔の人はね田んぼ作ったらその
田んぼに水を引きやすいか低いところに田んぼ作るんですよで家をその近くに立てるん
だけどその集落の中でやや高いところにいたぜてるんですよ
でだんだん旦那ちょっとずつ山によって言ってで時々山が崩れます
崩れたらそこに祠を建てたり神社を建ててここは悪いことが起こったしるしだよって
われわれに教えてくれてるんです
でもっと酷い事が起こるとその地名に鬼とかエビとかいう名前つけていくわけ
ソフトをにとか蛇とかつけたらそこに住みたくないですよねそう
いう知恵があったんです僕たち皆さんどうです
団部失ってますよねだから我々が今現代的にこれは何が必要かって言うとリスク管理な
んですよねリスクマネジメント急にカッコイイ話になるんですけれども
リスク管理ってのは一体何かっていうとまず危険をちゃんと特定することですよね
次にその危険がどれぐらいの割合で僕たちに発生することかということを分析をして
そして大佐
こう考えて実際の起こった時に対応しますと
でも簡単なことなんですねわかります
で今今日は南海トラフ地震が最後のターゲットなんですけどもそこに行く前に
ぽくたちが生きていく上でね遭遇するリスクについて考えてみたいと思う例えばこれ1
年
館で遭遇する人の数です何の数やと思います
これねー
警察署調べて出てますけれども平成29年1年間で交通事故によってお亡くなりになっ
た方へと経過した人の数です
60万人ですよすごいでしょ
ねっ
じゃあこれはどうです37万人
1年間ですこれもこれは国立がん研究書調べて書いてるかも分かりますよね
平成28年にがんでお亡くなりになった人の数です
さらに例えばおよそ7万3000件
日本一年間ですねこれも警察署調べなんですけれどもこれは空き巣にやられた
1年間の件数ですでこれが皆さん今交通事故と病気とそれから空き巣とありましたよね
皆さんそれのために多分準備してはります
きてますよね
ます
してませんかきてますよね安全運転したり自動車保険入ったり小学校行ってた時には車
に気をつけなさいと言われたし
が保険に入ったりねそれから家の鍵がこう開きにくいようにしたり後地下鉄活光る
ライトつけたしません
でこれがどれぐらい皆さんに降りかかるリスク買ってえっと日本の人口と世帯数で計算
します困難なんですよねぇ
30年リスクですこれ30年人間が生きたとしてね
をなくで魚交通事故で亡くなった気がしたりする確率はなんと15%100人25人
それかがんで死ぬした10人に1人ですおよそ空き巣は20件に意見です
なんとなく自分の身に降りかかると思いませんか
思いました
ねだからこれに合わせ等金かけてるわけです
で
畳みかけるようですいませんじゃあそれに対して皆さんにはこういうリスクがあるん
ですコレなにかも
わかりましたねこれはね国
発表した三重県津市今日我々つしいますけれども津市が今後30年以内に震度6弱以上
の揺れに見舞われる確率です
あんまり驚けませんかあそんなもんよなーって感じですかいや本当ですか
僕ね調べたんですよアンケート調査してね寝室の家具を
て折れないようにしている人の立三重県民で50%くらいですよ
残りの50%の人はた家具地震で倒れてきたら死ぬようなところで知ってて寝てるん
ですよ
この確率ですよお菓子ないですか
ねぇなんででしょうかねぇ
他にもねー南海撮ろう自身だけを捉えると今後30年間で南海トラフ地震が起きる確率
は70から80と言われています
なぜこれが認知できないんでしょうか不思議ですよねそれはしょう最初に申し上げまし
た
ヘルマンエビングハウスですつまり交通事故や
がんやあるいは空き巣ってそういうものを目にするチャンスが比較的あるんです
パラパラ起きるからね
だから思い出した青自分はなんだった困るわーと思うんですけども
地震と火災が入っていうのはやっぱりとなんとなく子フィルターの向こう側で見ていて
繰り返し繰り返し身近な人がダンヘンな目に遭うこと目あんまり
まあ
のあたりにしないからみんな人間は意識の外に置いてしまうんですねだから今日私が
一番言いたかったことはこういうリスクがある国に住んでいるということをもう1回
思い出して先人が我々に教えてくれたことをもう1回思い出さなければというふうに
思っていますさてそれを踏まえてもし皆さん
今ねこんな音がなったらどうしますか
音は後でやりましょうすいません1個間にもう1個いうのがありました
それができない理由はこれです正常性バイアス
を知っていますこれはどういうことかと言いますとね自分に降りかかる
嫌な事をこれは嫌な事こんな事が私の振りかかるはずがないんだとか
起きている事象をいやいやきっと大丈夫大丈夫と思い込む人間の本能です
人間をね日頃から big big big していく生活できないんですよ
宝鋼
いうね本能が備わっていてきっと大丈夫だって思うように出来てるんです
だから次に音を出しますけれどもびっくりしないで下さいねこれ訓練4戦です
これ聞いたことありますねこれは緊急地震速報でテレビでなる音声です我々一生懸命
考えて何にも似てないちゃいも考えたしましたそれがコレなんですよ
でこれがなるっていう事はねうまくいけば数十秒間本当に揺れがくるまでの猶予がある
というサインでテレビでこれがなったら
皆さんどうするんですかあるいはこんな音これも訓練音声なんですけどもねびっくりし
ないでくださいね
えっ
ブーッブーッ
これは携帯電話各社さんが緊急地震速報を流す時の音楽です聞いたことある人もいる
でしょう
でこれを聞いたらどうするかって
今皆さんそこにいたどうします
決めてませんか
僕は決めています僕は始めたここはうわわが大学ですから寝床に非常口があるかなんて
僕は熟知してますしね
今僕の上には恐ろしい照明があるのでもしこれがなったら
8みんなを見捨てて死ぬ気で走って逃げるで行こうと決めてるんですけれども
でも皆さんやっぱりね日頃からがそのことちょっとだけ考えてくださいなーんて
立って64%ですから
ねっで僕は例えばねー
東京なんか言って高いビルのルでしょでエレベータのらなあかん時に小さなことなん
ですけどもエレベーター乗る前に必ずトイレ行くんですよなんでか分かります
東日本大震災の時にね数百頭の塔高層タワーのエレベーターみんな止まったんですよね
行っ故障すればすぐに修理の人来てくれはるんですよ
だけど数百と故障したらまぁこないですよねそうすると下手したらね数時間から数十
時間エレベーターの中にいなきゃいけない
おしっこ行きたくなったらどうします少ないでしょう
だからそんな事を考えるでやっぱりへと防災対策って今まで僕思うんですけども小学校
でね揺れた付の所入りなさい
何故か知らないけど給食つから火が出て皆は武器のままグランドに並んで123して
やる
いやそれ自身が間違えたと言いませんでも
ああああああ
給食センターから給食とっている学校の給食つから日は出ないし
それからそもそも30年ぐらい調べても急所しから給食あの日が出た学校あんまないん
ですそれからね
ねぇ
何ですか何をとしたんだったから9職種の話があってそうそうそうそうねえっと上履き
のまま外へ出るだったじゃないですか
なぜてるんですか昔ね僕らの時代は1学年5クラス10クラスだったからみんなが早う
出て行かないとそこで詰まってしまうでもね1学年1クラス2クラスの家
者が学校になったらはば昨日は毎クール靴履いたほうがいいんちゃうかなと僕を守っ
たりする
でそれはやっぱり答えがこれですってさっきのを育っちゃっててそれやればいいん
でしょみたいな態度になってるこの感じ考える力っていうのがちょっと足らなくなって
これがこの100年で我々が昔から日本人が祖先を教えてくれたことを失っている
とつの例だというふうに思うんですねもう一つ現代病は
ねマニュアル主義ですつまり
マニュアルにこう書いてあるから交代をしなければいけないあるいは
災害の対応はマニュアル的にやらなければいけないみたいなことになって
間違いを犯してしまうことがないかなってちょっと思いますだからやっぱり昔の人が
自然が強いとか地震が起こった怖いということをちゃんと感じてそのために今できる
ベストが何かということを常に考え続ける
これが日本人がずっとやってきたことなんですぜひね皆さんにも
私あんまりね面白い話しなかったかもしれませんけれども
でもこの国に住むということはこういう音作法を身につけておかなければいけないこと
だというふうに僕は思うんです皆さんどう思いましたか
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]